all right guys
bang bang i've got eric here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
hey thanks for having me on palm for
sure uh
let's just jump right into i think
what's probably one of the most
interesting things that you've been uh
spending time on since last time we
had you on the podcast uh which is
shapeshift has essentially
transformed itself you've completely
ripped out all the centralized
infrastructure uh and you've really kind
of turned into this uh new
model uh where it's an interface to all
these decentralized protocols
just like what exactly does that entail
why did you do it and how's it going so
far
yeah so for most of our history
shapeshift was essentially an exchange
where we would
take one coin from one person and send a
different coin
from us so they would trade with us and
it was non-custodial and that we didn't
hold any balance
but we were essentially an intermediary
to each trade
and uh in 2018 that's what got us all
caught up
in all of the financial regulation and
in which we had to impose
kyc and i would call highly unethical
surveillance on people
which we've been fundamentally opposed
to
so we've been searching for a way out of
that you know we we can't
break laws but i also don't want to spy
on people and i don't want to be a
branch of the
government surveillance apparatus so how
do you
how do you square that and the way we
square it is by
integrating decentralized protocols now
so we no longer
are an intermediary in any way we do not
trade with customers
we are no longer a financial institution
and that means that we do not need to
kyc people it means that
we do not need to act like a bank and we
can let
users trade directly against these
decentralized protocols in a really
really cool way so we've completed that
transition now and as of
april 15th uh tax day ironically
we we are fully fully out of that mess
and so when you talk about this idea of
uh
a user coming to the platform uh using
your interface but they're actually
trading against the decentralized
protocol maybe give us an example like
how that works
yeah so shapeshift is a mobile app and
it's a web app
and you can hook up different types of
wallets to it right so you can use
portis or keepkey or ledger or trezr
and um basically you have you always are
in control of your own assets
right so you stay in control of your
keys always and you
interact with the interface you can see
your your digital assets in there
you can send and receive like a normal
wallet and you can do
trades between different digital assets
and those trades occur now between
your wallet and a decentralized
liquidity pool
so by january we had the major ethereum
dexes integrated
and uh the big asterisk to that is that
it only supports like ethereum assets
and the most important asset of all
bitcoin was not included
thor chain came along and we integrated
that and launched with them
uh in mid-april so now even bitcoin
itself you can trade in a decentralized
way
with no intermediary no kyc and full
self-custody
at all at all ants thor chain is
something i think people have
heard about uh it's got mixed reviews
from different communities i think that
the
folks that come from kind of the d5
perspective
uh or like the ethereum world they get
super excited about this multi-chain
world the ability to kind of flip back
and forth between different assets
without having to go to a common unit of
account
um and that you know kind of
infrastructure that thor chains built
really kind of empowers that view of the
world
the bitcoin community seems to be a
little bit more skeptical
or or uh not yet quite embracing it in
the same way
i know that you think um and have you
know kind of really bet the company on
this idea
uh but think that this is very
beneficial to bitcoin so maybe talk a
little bit about how does thor chain
work and
why do you think it's so valuable to uh
bitcoin and bitcoiners
yeah great question uh so all of the
decentralized exchanges to date
pre-13 uh were essentially built on
ethereum or more recently on finance
smart chain or solana
and those are all stuck to those
ecosystems so you can only trade the
assets that are in those ecosystems you
can only trade ethereum and erc20 tokens
on an ethereum
dex and you can wrap a bitcoin as an
ethereum
erc20 token but any bitcoiner knows that
a wrapped bitcoin is not a bitcoin
so that whole world is really
fascinating and powerful
but it had completely left out chains
that were not attached
to that ecosystem thor chain is the
first in the world liquidity pool that
works across chains
so it has a similar model to uniswap but
instead of
only being on ethereum it can actually
work on all
all chains so today you can trade the
only place in the world that you can
trade
bitcoin native unwrapped bitcoin to
tether
for example without any intermediary at
all
and for any bitcoiner who cares about
decentralization and immutability
the fact that 99.999 of all bitcoin
trading today happens with a custodian
uh at a kyc exchange sucks like that
that is a huge weak point in the entire
um the entire growth of this ecosystem
so 14 comes along and now people can
actually have immutability
in bitcoin at the exchange level this is
a huge development
and i think bitcoiners most of all
should be excited about that
and so when somebody comes and and uh is
using this
they're trading with a decentralized
liquidity pool
that then that participant whoever's
providing the liquidity they're
basically
getting uh a piece of or um
all of the transaction uh you know fees
that are getting paid by the person
that's maybe trading let's say tether
for bitcoin or vice versa
yeah so you'd have people you know
before you go to trade your
your bitcoin and tether there are people
who have deposited bitcoin
native bitcoin into a pool and native
tether
into a pool those pools themselves are
not held at any custodian
they are set up in a threshold signature
scheme which we get into if you want
but it's essentially a multi-sig
apparatus of validators
so those pools hold the assets and when
you trade tether for bitcoin
you are sending in your tether to the
tether pool and you're getting out
bitcoin from the bitcoin pool so you're
trading against a pool you're not
trading against any specific
counterparty and certainly not any
centralized custodian
and that makes it immutable it follows
the laws of the code it's all open
source obviously
works from anywhere in the world there
are no territory or geographic
restrictions it doesn't care
who you are you don't have to sign up
with an account send in your id and a
blood sample
it is the proper way to do exchange and
has just never been possible
on native bitcoin before got it
and then when you start to think about
uh kind of
that ecosystem obviously there's what
i'll call the shapeshift user right the
person who comes and uses the shapeshift
interface
and then there's the liquidity providers
themselves um
are you only participating from that
interface standpoint are there other
things that you would do in that
transaction to help facilitate it or
make it better for
the people trying to uh to do it right
now through shapeshift you can trade
over thor chain but you can't provide
liquidity yet so that's one of our next
objectives is to allow people to provide
liquidity um that will actually allow
people to earn
interest on bitcoin in an immutable way
for the first time which is super
exciting
but yeah so far it's just just the
trading
got it and so what's been the response
like you went from a
you know kind of traditional centralized
exchange kyc the whole nine yards
to now this what i think people uh are
just starting to wrap their heads around
uh but what i think is
likely to be one of the most interesting
and valuable ways to
have users interface with you um and so
once you got rid of the kyc
and and kind of move to the new model
what's been the response from the user
base
the thing that's made me happiest is
hearing customers
like exclaiming on twitter that [ __ ]
that like shapeshift is back
like we had a very dark couple years and
we lost literally more than 99 of our
business
following kyc like it completely
decimated the company
and um dealing with that you know for
two years through the bear market was
was pretty miserable three three years
really
so to hear people see how shapeshift
works now
where we can give them this frictionless
trading across
genes with noaa kyc and in a model in
which we're not violating any rules
that is you know that's profound so
customers have
really loved it and you know we're just
trying to help uh teach everyone that
like
that model is back now and it's because
the decentralized technology has gotten
to a point
where that can be offered and is kyc the
only thing that kind of was impacted
here so now you don't do the kyc but are
there other things that
kind of come out of that financial
regulation world uh
that are removed or friction reduced
yeah i think a lot of people don't
realize how much the tip of the iceberg
kyc is
any company that is doing kyc that's
that's what the user sees
right they have to give an id and at
best it's a
inconvenience there is an entire
surveillance apparatus
that lives below the surface of that
nonsense that most people don't see
in which companies are often not allowed
to tell you is going on
i find it highly unethical and the
problem is
when companies are coerced into doing
that they don't have much choice
right so you know the this is what's so
beautiful about
decentralized technology is that there's
no government that would have allowed
bitcoin to exist
unless it can exist in a structure that
can't be turned off
and that was its magic bitcoin arises
and cannot be turned off it is immutable
and decentralized
so much of the innovation in the
industry right now is about
bringing that principle of immutability
and decentralization
to other areas of finance that's what
all of d5 is trying to do
that's what decentralized exchanges are
trying to do and so that that
that principle that bitcoin started is
being applied now in wider areas of
finance and
this is super super fun and exciting
yeah and it feels like uh this shift
has definitely increased the privacy
right like i think that's kind of uh not
debatable
how much has the product had to change
from like a feature standpoint is it
just as rich
from a feature standpoint do you have
more features less features like what
was the impact there
yeah i mean to a user that used
shapeshift in in february
uh to user that uses it now the only
thing they'll notice is that they don't
have to kyc
so they lost nothing um they gained
their privacy back
and there's less friction to onboard
them so
um yeah for them it only got better
what's been the response are there
regulators or you know others that have
uh
have reached out or have you gotten any
feedback in terms of uh
you know making this transition from
kind of government organizations
we told the regulators ahead of time you
know we obviously are in talks with them
and have been for years
so we just went right up and told them
what we were doing
and um you know i my hope is that a lot
of the regulators understand that this
decentralized technology actually
achieves a lot of their aims like if a
regulator wants
transparency honest money
uh lack of fraud um
open systems that are accountable and
that do not hide risk
they should be very encouraged by a lot
of these decentralized applications
what they will have to accept is that
they are not going to be able to
control money in the degree that they
did before and they are not going to be
able to have this blanket surveillance
network over people's private financial
decisions
like they've had in the past i'm sure
some of them are
going to be okay with that trade-off and
others will will fight a tooth mail
so it's incumbent on everyone in the
industry i think to realize that that
struggle is coming
and the more the stuff grows and the
more the regulators lose the ability to
control
people's personal private decisions it's
going to be something that we have to be
very careful about that narrative and we
have to be constantly conveying the
benefits of an open immutable and honest
financial system
what's the way you guys make money now
right so
historically exchanges made money by uh
having trading fees my understanding is
that
uh through this interface you're not
actually adding any fees to what just
the decentralized
uh kind of liquidity pools uh require
so how do you guys make money yeah so
right now um
like we we have always been very long
crypto we hold a balance sheet of crypto
and we we've made plenty of money on
just the crypto market rising itself
we do not raise uh we do not make money
on trading fees we think that's a
commoditized service that'll tend
towards zero with time
so someone who's going through
shapeshift is getting the exact same
rate as if they went directly to unislop
directly the thor chain um and you know
in the future we have
different avenues to make some revenue
based on staking and lending markets uh
done through a non-custodial way
but yeah right now it's a it's a free
service and
and people can use it directly like that
what's up guys bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe
you get bitcoin back rather than
cashback or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user i think you will be too
when you go to blockfy.com pomp
again blockfy.com go check it out and
let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it one of
the things i want to spend a lot of time
talking about
is this idea of maximalism uh and
you know before we we recorded this i uh
tweeted out and said hey i'm having eric
on the podcast
uh what questions do you have for him
and there's all kinds of crazy stuff
there's some that were really thoughtful
intelligent
uh questions and then there was things
that basically
you know kind of try to paint you to be
an enemy of bitcoin i guess maybe let's
just start with like
what are your thoughts about bitcoin and
that ecosystem and then what are your
thoughts about
everything that's not bitcoin you know
do you support kind of both
and then how do you think about uh
almost participating in both ecosystems
at the same time
yeah good question it's good to start
with first principles like that
so i have been involved in bitcoin since
2011.
it is you know like my first life's
passion
it has been my career it has been my
hobby it has been my passion for a
decade
and when i found bitcoin i saw in it
a solution to what i thought was the
biggest problem in the world which is
government's control over money
so everything i do since
then has been to help bring bitcoin to
the world
now bitcoin is a complicated technology
and society is a complicated
thing to bring that technology to um and
as bitcoin has grown
i have seen the value in other systems
that are built on blockchains
also being in partnership with bitcoin
so i see it as one ecosystem right i see
the decentralization that bitcoin
promised
best expressed when there are other
blockchains and there are other systems
i do not think a monolithic chain that
handles everything for everyone and
solves all
problems is decentralization i think
that's a that's
that would be a weaker more brittle
structure part of the
dynamism and part of the strength and
resiliency of
a decentralized financial world is one
built on multiple blockchains that
optimize for different things
bitcoin has taken a very conservative
approach to optimizing to be
the best form of money ever made by
mankind i think it has done better at
that than any other
project easily uh most of my net worth
is and always has been in bitcoin and
will continue to be
and yet i see ethereum as an extremely
valuable ecosystem
i see zcash and monero and haven and
privacy coins as extremely important
tools
for financial privacy i see this stuff
getting built in defy
and how how much destruction that will
rain down on the entire banking system
and all i can do is applaud that and so
when people get mad at me because i'm
not only bitcoin
uh it it saddens me it's like you know
what what are you
what are you actually here for are you
here for orange coin
or are you here to actually bring
decentralized finance and a new
form of money to the entire world
because the other communities that are
building around bitcoin
are have that same mission and they
should be seen as allies instead of
enemies
this is really interesting because i
think that um
ever since i met you right uh it's never
uh been at question right i think your
commitment to bitcoin
and and wanting to see it be successful
i think throughout history
of bitcoin uh there's been all sorts of
debates and opportunities and
and uh various points in time where uh
people
did debate you know what's the best way
to bring it forward but i always try to
remind people that
uh you know everyone is trying to
accomplish the same goal
the path to get there is where the
debates occur but i don't think that
anyone
uh who has spent as much time as you
have or others
uh in bitcoin want to see it fail right
or or for some reason
uh don't believe in it etc right kind of
ridiculous
it's such an absurd notion um and it
worries me because bitcoin does have
some very serious enemies
and we have only started to awaken those
enemies
and so if the bitcoin community and if
the larger crypto community itself
is infighting all the time and just
tearing each other down
they are going to be missing the actual
enemy
which is the state which is the banking
system that is what this stuff is
in opposition to bitcoin is not in
opposition to ethereum
it is no coincidence that the two
systems have grown up together and are
hitting all-time highs together
they are collaborative they are
community together and
that stands in stark contrast to fiat
currency to the banking system
and to states which try to control money
from the from the center
so i i want people to orient their
vision outside of those proper
enemies because there are many of them
yeah and when you think about
uh the technology it seems like uh
there's a thought process of almost uh
on a
kind of horizontal standpoint all of the
technology that is going after true
decentralization and is trying to bring
uh some sort of uh value or
functionality
uh to this decentralized digital
ecosystem uh via
decentralized open protocols you're a
fan of right you're saying hey
this is all good it's all moving us in
their uh right direction
but then there's this like social layer
right
and the social layer is everything that
doesn't involve the technology and this
is where you get the maxwell
maximalism the tribalism uh the the
marketing messages
the infighting all that kind of stuff
and so
is that stuff healthy is it agnostic
like does it actually not matter at all
it's just whatever the technology that
works ends up being the most important
thing and
everything else just a distraction like
how do you think about the social layer
maybe different than the technology
layer
yeah and the social layer is really like
the most important one which most people
don't recognize this this is technology
meant to be used by humans and lives to
serve humans
um i think it's important and and what a
lot of the maximalists do
correctly is to have a very high degree
of skepticism
toward any project right whether it's a
bitcoin company
or whether it's some new chain or coin
there's a lot of crap out there there's
a lot of garbage
there are a lot a lot of scams
absolutely
so i would never want people to just
like blanketly accept anything in the in
the ecosystem because it's crypto
most of the stuff is garbage and yet
there is a
core of projects which are legitimate
run by very smart people that
share uh these ideologies and which are
building
world-changing technology and so to just
be open-minded to the things which have
quality uh i think is important and if
everything is called a scam
you get a phenomenon just like how the
you know how the government says like
you should never do drugs right just say
no
and you get this whole generation rising
up and realizing that oh if they smoke a
joint with a friend
and they didn't die maybe the government
is actually wrong about other things
uh it's like don't lose your credibility
by calling every project in crypto other
than your favorite coin of scam
it does not help anyone and i think it
only
it only perpetuates like a an atmosphere
of animosity and doesn't actually get to
the truth of what these projects are
yeah what's your process for evaluating
a project how much of it is technology
based for social based versus like the
team
um just just how do you kind of somebody
tells you something
says hey you know somebody's building
something new what's your process
yeah so in uh in the last bull market in
2017 and the crazy ico days
um i think it was actually quite a bit
harder because everything was a promise
all the new projects were a white paper
and they're like yeah i'm gonna raise a
bunch of money and someday we're gonna
launch something and so it was actually
quite hard to vet
what was legitimate and what was not
today the biggest difference in this
bull market
even though there's still a lot of
garbage everything has actually shipped
so you can go use these things so you
don't have to read a white paper at all
today you can go use a protocol
and if you're an engineer you can
actually read the code and see how it
works
um i think that's that's the best way i
mean the
what what helped me learn about bitcoin
in 2011 wasn't reading a bunch of
articles about it or even perusing the
bitcoin talk forums
those were a good start but what really
got me to understand bitcoin was when i
first downloaded the bitcoin d
client and received some and then sent
some to a friend and used it
when you use these systems that is
absolutely the best way to learn about
them
and when i saw that bitcoin just worked
uh that was what really helped me
see that it was a legitimate project and
it didn't matter what any article
uh was saying about it yeah it's
fascinating the difference between
uh kind of marketing messages and what
needed to be said or done
uh from a fundraising perspective versus
now uh just shipping the thing and
actually seeing you know do people use
it or not it's a much healthier
uh kind of uh mechanism yeah
absolutely if something is shipped and
is usable that's
that's like a should be a criteria for
anyone to take a project seriously
yeah and i'm assuming at shape shift uh
rather than having like listing criteria
right when you're not a centralized
exchange there's almost this like
onboarding right so how do you choose uh
which protocols to interface with which
one's not to
uh is it similar hey if other people are
using it and it's got traction and the
things shipped
then you're looking to add it or add
support for it or is there some other
way to evaluate yeah
so first we realized we need to
replicate what we're doing as an
exchange
with a decentralized exchange so that
that feature we needed to
add before we removed it ourselves so
that meant we had to add one of these
these dexes um you know uniswap being
the biggest one we actually ended up
using a
aggregator from 0x that pulls orders
across multiple ethereum
dexes so we integrated that and then we
integrated thor chain so that we could
add
other chains like bitcoin um up next
i think we'd really like to get into
some of the lending markets like like
ave or compound
those are really cool um i think a lot
of people don't realize today that you
can like
put put up crypto into a smart contract
borrow stable coins against it and buy a
house
uh without any intermediary of any kind
uh this is something that like you
couldn't do a year ago
so we're trying to see which of those
systems are getting used and which ones
our customers want and then bring those
protocols into shapeshift but it is a
lot to keep up with and like there's no
way we can
we can bring it all in it's kind of
overwhelming yeah
and the user base uh completely global
right once you have this interface you
don't have kind of the kyc requirements
uh you pretty much can serve anyone in
the world with an internet connection
yes we serve anyone in the world with an
internet connection with the exception
of ofac countries
so countries that are on the ofac list
we do not allow
through our web or mobile service um of
course the decentralized protocols
themselves
someone can go directly to them but we
do that filter
on our own that is still a rule that as
an american
based company we have to follow
unfortunately
yeah and really that's uh not so much
around the financial
regulation or surveillance as much as it
is or i guess it's not around financial
surveillance
as much as it is more the the um kind of
law enforcement and uh criminal side
uh it's both yeah okay a lot of people
don't realize that ofac
actually uh applies to all companies um
and you are not permitted to do business
with anyone from certain
uh certain countries so the reason this
is so absurd is like
iran for example is on the offec list
it's illegal for any american business
to do any business with anyone in iran
iran is like one of the largest
countries in the world in terms of
people it's got like
40 40 million people uh i would bet that
99
of them are great human beings and yet
we are not permitted
to work with them because of their
government uh
i think that's horrible and i'm glad
that at least on the protocol level
you know bitcoin does not discriminate
bitcoin does not check an offec list
um bitcoin does not care where you were
born or what color your skin is or what
your government does
bitcoin is just an open immutable money
for the world and i think that's so
important and to see that
getting built out to these other layers
of finance is really special
how do you think about uh the state's
response
to all of this so we saw el salvador um
kind of
adopt bitcoin as legal tender uh the imf
seems to uh
i'll quote them have concerns
whatever that ends up meaning um and
then obviously you have all the
decentralized protocols you've got
uh you know kind of what you guys are
doing with no kyc and
doing it in kind of a legally compliant
way just
what do you think their take is or is
there really doesn't really matter what
they kind of socially believe
or or what their philosophical belief is
they just can't do anything about it
i think that the governments are
generally like
three to six years behind the industry
so they
at this point kind of understand bitcoin
uh they really don't understand d5 at
all yet they have kind of like a
2013-2014 view of the crypto landscape
they do not realize what is actually
going to happen which is that
bitcoin is going to continue emerging as
the better form of money and is
ultimately going to out compete fiat all
over the world
they have too much hubris and too little
understanding of how monetary economics
actually works
to to be able to acknowledge that fiat
is going to decay in front of a sound
money that the whole world can use
so i'm grateful that they have that
ignorance because i think if they
recognize the existential threat that
bitcoin poses to
all fiat currencies the hostilities
would have been much louder much earlier
hopefully bitcoin gets large enough fast
enough
before they realize the existential
threat
that enough powerful people will
actually own it by then
and the the inertia to prevent it from
growing will
will be diminished but that's that's the
big experiment that's what we'll see
how important is it that the banks the
financial institutions themselves are
starting to adopt bitcoin
is there safety in that like the fact
that it's not just a bunch of random
strangers on the internet that are
individuals
but now you've got public companies
holding it you've got you know financial
institutions
uh within the united states that are in
good standing that
uh are generally well respected by that
type of
uh kind of political you know class
does that help bitcoin i think it helps
it hugely
yeah um the more credible it is in the
eyes of people who
only look at superficial things to judge
credibility
the better so it is good that it has
taken you know this decade
for bitcoin to grow to its current size
i think if it grew faster
if it if all of this development thus
far it happened in a year or two
i think the reaction against bitcoin
would have been much stronger but it is
definitely seeping
into the financial infrastructure of the
world um
that's that's great now will that
continue happening
as the banks realize that this isn't
just a financial asset that people trade
but it is actually coming directly at
the heart of the financial system
i don't know how commercial banks will
feel about that certainly central banks
will be
completely opposed to it they will they
will have concerns
because it's essentially going to make
them all redundant and not only will
they be losing
their jobs but they think that they are
doing an important service for the world
they think that that money itself needs
to be centrally planned and controlled
in a market economy which is of course
[ __ ] but they think that that's
important so they will see this as
an enemy they will see this as something
diabolical that needs to be put down
but they do not they do not have any
conception that is actually a legitimate
threat to money yet
so hopefully it goes for at least a few
more years without them coming to terms
with that
yeah and then what about the uh
financial institutions and their
response to uh kind of the entire d5
ecosystem uh is that something where
you know some percentage start to
participate and then they
uh kind of get out right that they
survive
uh but the ones who thumb their nose
they end up suffering at the
at the feet like how does that work the
i think the the most important point
here is that d5 is happening
so fast that even for those of us who
are involved in it
we can't keep up like a year ago i was
completely ignorant on defy
and i'm in the crypto industry all day
every day i'm
i'm starting to catch up i have an
understanding of some of it but
but even me like i can't i can't get it
all there is no way
that any financial institution has any
conception of what is coming from them
this d5 stuff is is as powerful to
to financial tooling as bitcoin was to
money
and they're going to be completely
washed over by this stuff now it doesn't
mean that like
all banks are going away or all
financial institutions are going away
but just in the same way that the
internet completely
decimated then transformed and regrew
entire industries around it
uh bitcoin ethereum defy
cryptocurrency and decentralized finance
generally is going to do that to
the banking establishment um and
obviously these are slow-moving
institutions you know they have to have
15 committee meetings probably even to
to talk about what this stuff all means
there's no way that they're going to
keep up and it's going to wash over them
like a flood
yeah it's absolutely fascinating when
you start to think about the
the power shift right the the wealth
shift uh that occurs here
um when you think about uh talent
it seems like if young if you're a young
person
a lot of people want to work at banks
now i want to work in crypto right they
want to go work
uh on a bitcoin company they want to
work on a decentralized protocol
uh are you seeing that on the ground um
in terms of the folks that you hire
the folks that you talk to that are
joining the industry or is that maybe
over generalization and still majority
of the folks who want to quote
work in finance uh they still want to
work at the jp morgans the goldman sachs
and those places
i think it is largely true and it makes
a lot of sense
i mean generally people have to choose
in life between doing something that is
you know emotionally or ideologically
fulfilling something they really care
about or passionate about or
making a bunch of money right and often
people that will go into traditional
finance
have chosen the latter and frankly i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that necessarily as long as they're not
being
evil but crypto comes along and actually
now you can do both you can do something
that is ideologically fascinating
and which you can get fabulously wealthy
doing so why in the world would you ever
go join a
bank right i mean who who in their right
mind is leaving
leaving school seeing the state of play
in finance
and saying you know what i'm going to go
make 200 a year over at this bank or 500
grand a year over this bank
right you can make that much or more
joining a crypto company and change the
world while you do it
so yeah anecdotally we see this we see
people will join shapeshift from the
traditional world
and even if they're leaving shape shift
they don't go back to the traditional
world they go to a different crypto
company
right like this black hole is sucking
everyone in
i uh i always feel weird sometimes i
like walk around
new york or miami and i just look around
me
99 of people have no clue what's
happening they have no clue what's going
on and
it kind of feels like we know a secret
to some degree
uh and you know my greatest wish is that
everyone
figures it out uh because it is the
first time
you know at least in my lifetime where
individuals actually have the ability to
kind of front run those institutions
right to get access to things uh before
the institutions
and that doesn't mean that you're
guaranteed to get wealthy
or or be right in certain situations
whatever
but the opportunity exists and so you
still got to take the action you got to
educate yourself all that but but it
does feel like there's a paradigm
difference here between you know pretty
much every other trend uh of my lifetime
where institutions are just
you know they've got more capital
they've got more intellectual horsepower
and they're able to kind of get ahead of
it before individuals figure it out
yeah bitcoin crypto is a great equalizer
right it is going to bring fabulous
wealth across the world
and is going to care very little about
who you are or where you're from
um it is going to pull resources away
from
centralized areas like manhattan and
distributed across the world but it's
not just
redistributing wealth that is actually
creating new wealth because it's a
better form of money
society will be more efficient will be
more honest more transparent and it will
have a
more solid foundation on which to build
all other kinds of businesses right if
you fix money
you allow the world to heal and
we have lived in a world of sick money
for
many decades you know over 100 years i
would say
i uh i could not agree more uh before we
finish up
uh just what's your pitch to people
right so people who are out there who
use
centralized exchanges uh or are
interested in
uh finding a new exchange uh to use
what's your pitch as to why they should
consider shapeshift or maybe some of the
others
yeah so shape-shift is a self-custody
crypto platform
so if you ever hear people talking about
not your keys not your coins that's a
very important message right it means
the entire point of bitcoin is that you
are sovereign over your money
and you're only sovereign over your
money if you control your keys so i have
no problem with the coin bases of the
world
i think they're great companies i have
used them before but if that's the
that's as far as you get into crypto you
haven't actually
understood it um shape-shift i think is
the step
after that right where you are ready to
take responsibility and control of your
own keys
your own wealth and um to have a little
bit more
understanding of the purpose of this
stuff and it is slightly harder than
using a coinbase but not
not much and so if you want to use
an easy service where you maintain
control of your wealth and you get that
self-sovereign
attribute over money shapeshift is a
great way to do that
and uh shapeshift is one of the only
non-custodial services in the world that
supports
not just ethereum but many of the
different
blockchains and now you can trade across
them
no kyc and and maintaining your privacy
and dignity
i think that is a a pretty compelling
pitch there
the the idea of giving people freedom of
choice uh
and uh and doing it in a uh a more
private way
um is uh is likely to become a more
popular way of viewing the world
uh and then when you have the
decentralized protocols uh
it you know i think we both agree that
uh legacy banks legacy financial
institutions
you know writings on the wall and we'll
see kind of how it plays out
yeah yeah they're they're in trouble and
i'm just i'm so inspired really by all
the awesome entrepreneurs in this
industry that are building this stuff
it's really
it's a i'm proud to be part of it where
can we send people
to find out more about shapeshift or
find you on the internet
yeah shapeshift.com best place for that
uh
and i am at eric voorhees on twitter
erik eric voorhees on twitter
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this uh it's pretty
incredible to watch you guys
uh essentially just rip out that
centralized infrastructure create a
interface for the decentralized world
and uh cheering you on from the
sidelines so
uh excited to see where you guys go next
awesome thanks palm
glad to be on